บ่
แคร์สวัสดีครับครูเอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะครูนิสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนพอดีนัก
เรียนทุกคนครับหน้าสวัสดีครับ
อะไรนะคะสบายดีไหมสบายดีค่ะค่ะครูนิคนะคะ
สบายดีครับคุณนิดอื่นแล้วก็อาบน้ำแล้วก็
มีกาแฟ
ดื่มได้ค่ะดื่มกาแฟนะคะนักเรียนที่ดูแล้ว
ก็ฟังเรียนภาษาไทยจากคุณนิแล้วก็ครูเอ๋ก็
ดื่มแม่ด้วยได้ค่ะไงลืมแต่ถ้าเขาอยู่ที่
ไทยยตอนนี้ดื่มกาแฟไม่น่าจะดีหรอเหอะไม่
เพราะว่ามันกลางคืนแต่เขาจะไม่ได้นอน
คนที่บ้านครูเอ๋ดื่มกาแฟถึง 4 ทุ่มก็ดื่ม
กาแฟจ
มาถึงแล้วอ่ะเอ่อคุณนี้ก็ดื่มกาแฟตอนกลาง
คืนเหมือนกันบางครั้งครับใช่มันก็เวลา
เวลาที่อยากจะเหมือนกับท้องมันไม่ค่อยทำ
งานดีอ่าดึงกาแฟดำก็กินเสร็จแล้วมันก็จะ
แบบช่วยให้แบบใช่
ระบาย
ท้องจะสบาย
ใช้คำว่าระบายจะได้สบายนี้ฟังแล้วสบาย
ราคา
ไอ้นักเรียนบอก What  is ระบายมายคือ
Smile ขี่ไปห้องน้ำแล้วก็ไม่ต้องนานๆ
ชายระบาย
ตอนแรกก็แบบรู้สึกดีครอบนะคะมันมันอะไรนะ
เราคุณต้องแน่น
ระบายออกแล้วสบาย
ใจขันสนามลูกกินตอนเช้าไม่ใช่เหรอคะ
สำหรับระบายก็กินด้วยครับก็ก็เช้าเย็น
ระบายได้หมดโอเค
ระบาย
จะใช้คำสุภาพหน่อยระวัง
บางทีไปกินข้าวหมูกะทะแล้วมันเยอะเกินไป
ซึ่งศ.ชายก็ต้องระบายท้องใช่มั้ยระบาย
ท้องออกไปนะคะๆๆหรือระบายลำไส้เช็คระบาย
ท้องก็ได้เนาะระบายลำไส้นะคะก็ได้กินแล้ว
ก็กระเพาะแล้วก็จริง
ไม่
ใช่ก็ได้เหมือนกันนะครับเพราะว่าไส้ก็คือ
อยู่ในท้องเหมือนกันตั้งแต่
โอเค
เราก็และสุขภาพกันนิดนึงก่อนจะเข้าไป
เรื่องนิทานนิทานจะดีของเรานะคะอะไรครับ
ก็วันนี้จะเป็นนิทาน
นิทานนิทานไทยนิทานทั่วโลกเอ่ออันนี้เป็น
นิทานอีสปครับก็จริงๆแล้วนิทานอีสปเนี่ย
ไม่มาจากต่างประเทศค่ะขอขอเอามาเปลี่ยน
ให้เป็นภาษาไทยแล้วก็ทำให้เหมือนกับเข้า
กับวัฒนธรรมไทยทุกรูปภาพอะไรพวกนี้ครับ
ให้คนไทยอ่านแล้วเข้าใจง่ายแล้วก็นิทาน
อีสปก็จะสอนนะคะเราอ่านเสร็จสนุกแต่ว่ามี
สอนสอนเด็กๆนะคะสอนผู้ใหญ่ก็ได้ให้คิดนะ
คะชายคิดว่าเอาเรื่องนี้ดีเรื่องนี้ไม่ดี
ต่อไปเขาคุณ
ดูข่าวเรื่องที่คุณที่จะเล่าเนี่ยเราเล่า
เลยไหมแล้วให้นักเรียนคอมเมนต์ตอนจบว่า
ชื่อเรื่องอะไร
ได้ได้ครับได้แบบนั้นก็ดีเหมือนกันใช่
ครับอยากรู้ว่านักเรียนเคยฟังเรื่องนี้
ไหมแล้วนิทานเรื่องนี้ชื่อเรื่องอะไรนะ
จริงๆเป็นจริงๆก็น่าสนใจนะครับเพราะว่า
คุณนี้คิดว่าเรื่องนี้เนี่ยมีหลายภาษาไม่
ใช่ทำหมาไทยอย่างเดียวอาจจะมีภาษาอังกฤษ
หรือเป็นภาษาของนักเรียน
แต่วันนี้นักเรียนก็ได้ฟังในภาษาไทยเฮ้ย
ถ่ายครับแต่เดี๋ยวคุณเล็กจะลืมอะไรคะเรา
ยังไม่ได้บอกว่าวันนี้วันอะไรอ่ะ
คิดว่าลืมกันจริงๆแล้วค่ะ F
ถ้าเกิดเน็ตได้เดี๋ยวคืนนี้ก็แชร์หน้าจอ
นะครับถ้า
เชิญค่ะโอเคราคาจากประวัติครูให้ใหญ่ขึ้น
มั่ว
โอเคครับ
เอเขียนไหมคะได้ครับได้ครับแต่เดี๋ยวคน
นี้จะขีดไว้ก่อนว่าให้เขียนถึงตรงไหน
เพราะว่านี้จะค่ะอะไรครับโอเคคุณนี่กับ
ผู้หญิงเหมือนกันต้องบอกเขตกูเอง
กด x2 จากใครก็บอกไว้ก่อนเพราะว่าเดี๋ยว
เขาจะเขียนเลยแล้วก็เออไม่เห็นครับ
โอเคได้ค่ะวันนี้วันอะไรทั้งคุณนี้วันนี้
วันนี้วันจันทร์ครับวันจันทร์สีเหลือง
เนาะขาว
วันจันทร์ที่
เมื่อวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 4 ครับวัน
ที่ 4 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนมิถุนายนครับ
เดี๋ยวนะไม่ใช่สิเปลี่ยนแล้วคุณนี้เป็น
วัน
เกิดคุณที่กะอยู่ที่อเมริกายังจำไม่ได้
เลยรัชดาคมครับเดือน
กรกฎาคม 7 วันนี้ยังชอบเดือนที่แล้วอยู่
ก็ขึ้นคุณนิคน่ะ 2 เดือนหน้าจะชอบจำจีน
เพราะมันภาษาอังกฤษเนี่ยมันเจอยู่เหมือน
กันเจอยู่เหมือนกันนะครับโอเค
เดือนกรกฎาคมปีพตอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ทำปีคศอะไรคะ
2022 ครับอ่ะแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะคุณ
จะรีบครับที่อเมริกานะครับที่เมืองที่คุณ
นิคอยู่เนี่ยเวลา
8:00 น
19 นาทีตอนเช้า
8 โมง 19 นาทีนะคะอ๋อทิประเทศไทยประเทศ
ไทยนะคะกี่โมงครับตอนนี้ที่เทศไทยเอาตอน
นี้ก็ 8:00 นสิบยี่สิบแปดโมงน 8:00 น
8:00 น 19 นาทีค่ะโอเคโอเคโอเคเราก็จะ
พูดกันจนถึง 20:00 น 49 นาที
หรือ
08:49 นะคะ
คุย - คือ - ๆคนที่
วันนี้เราจะมาฟังครูนิเล่านิทานนะคะอ่า
โอเคขับรถเสร็จแล้วค่ะได้นายครับอันนี้ก็
ตอบเด็กเวลาเราจะเล่านิทานต้องมีคำว่าการ
อักครั้งหนึ่งเออ
จริงๆมีก็ได้มีก็ได้ครับกาลครั้งหนึ่ง
จริงๆแล้วก็เพราะว่าคนไทยนะเวลาเล่านิทาน
จะ
จะเป็นนิทานหรือจะเป็นเรื่องที่นานมาก
แล้วเราก็เลยจะการละครั้งหนึ่งบางคนต้อง
กาลครั้งหนึ่งนานมาแล้วมี
อะไรคนนี้คนนั้นชาย
ชอบคำนี้การละครั้งหนึ่งนานว่ารักทองคำใน
อยู่หน้าพรุ่งนี้กะพอเวลาได้ยินน่ะคุณนี้
เจอคิดถึงเวลาแบบคุณนี่ใกล้จะนอนแล้วโทร
หานิตาส่วนใหญ่ก็จะเล่าตอนก่อนนอนให้เด็ก
ฟังเราทำคุณเล็กไม่รู้ว่าทำไมเวลาได้ยิน
ว่าการละครั้งมาแล้วคุณนิเจอร์แบบโอเครับ
เลส
ง่วงนอนโอเคพร้อมพร้อมแล้วเราเล่าให้ฟัง
เลยแต่ได้นอน
โอเคถ้าอย่างนั้นเราไม่พูดคำนี้ดีกว่าค่ะ
เดี๋ยวนะคะเดี๋ยวเดี๋ยวคลิปดอกไปคนนี้จะ
ไม่ตื่นมาส่งกับครูอีก
อ่ะเข้าเรื่องเลยค่ะข้างๆครับที่นี้ครับ
ก็เดี๋ยวคุณนิคจะบอกให้ฟังก่อนว่าในนิทาน
เรื่องนี้เนี่ยจะมีมีครับอ๋อรู้จักตัว
ละครก่อนเนอะอ้าวอันนี้ต้องหมายทำนายตาย
แล้วก็ที่ต้นไม้มีใครคะใช่ใครครับอันนี้
ครับก็คนไทยก็จะเรียกว่าเทพาพักค่ะ
เทพารักษ์จริงๆจะมีอีกชื่อหนึ่งครับแต่
ชื่อนี้เนี่ยอ่ะถ้าคุณเล็กอะไม่ค่อยได้
ใช้ก็เลยจะจัดไฟได้จะไม่คู๋จะใช้บ่อย
เมื่อกี้สองคนคุยกัน
เทพารักษ์ก็
คือนักเรียนคลาสเทพารักษ์เนี่ยก็คือเทวดา
นะคะเทวดานางว่าเป็นคนอยู่สวรรค์เนี้ย
เทวดาถ้ามีเทวดาที่อยู่บนโลกที่คอยดูแลดู
แลคอยรักษาเป็นเหมือนบอดี้การ์ดเนาะคอยดู
แลคอยปกป้องนะคะอาจจะอยู่ต้นไม้ก็ปกป้อง
ต้นไม้ถ้าอยู่ที่บ้านคนก็ปกป้องคนนะคะปก
ป้องที่ดินนะคะอันนะคะเทพารักษ์เหมือนกัน
แต่พออยู่ต่างที่ก็จะมีต่างชื่ออีกหยุด
เทพารักษ์ที่อยู่ต้นไม้ก็เรียกว่าลูกค้า
เทวดา
ข่าวกะเทพารักษ์ที่อยู่ที่บ้านหน้าที่
เป็นสารเล็กๆเหมือนบ้านเล็กๆเราก็จะเรียก
ว่าพระภูมิๆชายก็เขาว่าวันนี้เราให้ชื่อ
เทพารักษ์เนาะๆก็นักเรียนจะได้เอ่อจำได้
ง่ายขึ้นใช่อยากจะจำอีกทำว่าเป็นรูปค้า
เทวดาตาได้กันใช้เพราะว่ามันกี่คะนัก
เรียนฟังบางที่เขาก็จะเรียกว่าลูกค่ะ
เทวดา
หรือเรียกว่าเทวดาเฉยๆได้ไหมได้ไหมจริงๆ
แล้วเนี่ยสำหรับคุณนี้ก็คิดว่าได้เพราะ
ว่าถ้าเป็นเพราะว่าลิปหักอีสปเนี่ยเขา
เป็นของกริชใช่ภาษาอังกฤษก็จะเรียกว่า
เป็นเทวดา
ชายภาษาไทยก็เป็นเทพารักษ์เทพารักษ์เลย
ลูกค้าเทวดานะคะถ่ายแบบคนที่เออเป็นเทพ
เป็นเตือนเทวดาที่คอยดูแลในอยู่ตรงหน้า
ที่อยู่ในต้นไม้ค่ะชายต้นไม้ตัวนี้อยู่
ใกล้ๆน้ำด้วยใช่ครับอยู่ใกล้ๆน้ำครับน้ำ
ก็จะอยู่ตรงนี้
น้ำก็จะอยู่ตรงนี้แหละ
เดี๋ยวกูอีกวะ
ขอโทษขอโทษขอ
หมดมันใหญ่ไปใช่ไหม
เดี๋ยวคุณที่ขยับให้นิดนึง
อย่างนี้นะ
เอาสูงก็ได้ค่ะอ๋อโอเคโอเคแล้วตรงนี้โอเค
ไม่ได้แล้วจากนี้จะให้อยู่ตรงไหน
อยู่ใกล้ๆ
น้องน้ำที่ใหญ่มากใช่ไหม
ใหญ่แล้วก็ลึกนะลึกลับและใหญ่
โอเคเขาแล้วว่าสัตว์น้ำให้แล้วค่ะเมื่อ
กี้เล็กสระแล้วหนองน้ำ
อ่าโอเคเรียบคนไทยบางคนก็เรียกบ่อน้ำไหม
ครับตัดฟังว่าบ่นะเหมือนจะเป็นแบบเล็กๆ
เล็กๆหมอน้ำถ้าสระน้ำก็จะใหญ่ขึ้นมาถ้า
หนองน้ำก็จะใหญ่มากแต่ชอบมึงก็ใหญ่กว่า
ชาติชาติทะเลสาบก็ยิ่งใหญ่เข้าไปใหญ่เลย
ค่ะๆ
คนนี้คิดว่าบางครั้งบางคนพอได้ยินว่าสระ
น้ำเหนียวจะนึกถึงสระนํ้าน้ำใช่เพื่อไป
ว่ายน้ำที่อยู่ในโรงเรียนหรืออยู่ในที่
เล่นกีฬาค่ะงั้น
หนองน้ำก็ได้ครับจะได้ครับน้องน้ำแต่จริง
ๆในหนองน้ำหรือในบึงก็ลงไปว่ายน้ำได้
เหมือนกันได้ไม่
ได้ทำให้ลึกค่ะเก็บมันลึก
ลงไปคนก็จะกลัวได้ไหมได้ๆ
เนื้อหาธาตุพัดปืนคือไม่ลึกมากซักประมาณ
ครึ่งเมตรหนา 1 เมตรก็ยังโอเคแต่ถ้า 2
เมตร 3 เมตร 4 เมตร 5 เมตร10เมตรกูนึก
คำใช่ก็ในเรื่องนี้จริงๆนะหนองน้ำมันนี้
เนี่ยคุณนี้คิดว่าเป็นหนองน้ำที่ลึก
เพราะว่ามันมีเหตุการณ์มันมีเรื่องเกิด
ขึ้นเกี่ยวกับน้องน้ำนี่แหละแล้วก็
เทพารักษ์นะครับก็มีมินิตัวละครอื่นด้วย
เนี่ยมีตัวละครอื่นครับก็ตัวละครอีกตัว
ละครนึงเนี่ยจะอยู่วันนี้เดี๋ยวคงมีจะเอา
มาให้น้องน้ำของกูเอง
กลับมาให้ครับ
โอเคออกไปอ้าดีๆ
ราคา
คนนี้ก็จะเอาให้ดูอันนี้ครับตอนนี้เนี่ย
เป็นมีคนเป็นคนที่เนี่ยเราจะเรียกว่าเป็น
คนตัดไม้เขาเป็นผู้ชายเนาะใช่เป็นผู้ชาย
ครับก็จะเป็นคนที่เขาเข้ามาในป่าแล้วก็
ตัดไม้แล้วก็เอาไม้ไปขายหรือเอาไปใช้มือ
หรือคือตัดไม้เนี่ยถ้าเอาไปขายเป็นต้นก็
คนตัดไม้แต่ถ้าเมื่อไหร่ก็ตัดเป็นท่อน
เล็กๆเล็กๆแบบนี้เดี๋ยวเป็นว่าให้
เขาถ้าเขาตัดไม้แล้วตัดให้เหลือเป็นท่อน
แบบนี้แบบนี้แล้วคนเอาไม้อันนี้ไปเป็นจุด
ไฟนะคะไปทำฟืนอาจะเรียกว่าคนตัดฟืนเขาหา
คนตัดเฟิร์นอะตัดตัดไม้ตัดฟืนก็เหมือนกัน
เน๊อะอยู่นั่นก็มาจากต้นไม้เหมือนกันแต่
แค่เป็น in ที่เป็นต้นไม้ที่เล็กมันก็
เป็นชิ้นเล็กกว่าถ้ากินก็จะเรียกว่าฟืน
แต่ถ้าเป็นต้นใหญ่ๆก็จะเรียกส่งนะคะใหญ่ๆ
เราเรียกว่าชิ้นหรือเราเรียกว่าท่อนท่อน
ตัวกูนี้กะใช้ชิ้นบ่อยคือ
หมายฟืน 1 ชิ้นสองชิ้นแล้วนึกถึง 1 ท่อน 2
ค่ะ
อัน
คนไทยบางคนก็พูดเหมือนกันหมดเลยอ่านชิ้น
คือคือถ้าคิดอะไรไม่ออกก็เสียอันไปก่อนนะ
คะใช่เราจะไม่ง่ายๆโอเคก็อันนี้เขาก็จะ
เป็นก็ในในเรื่องนี้ครับก็จะมีคนตัดไม้
เนี่ยสองคนค่ะ 2 คนนะคะเป็นเพื่อนกันไหม
คะเป็นเพื่อนกันครับเป็นเพื่อนกันชายสอง
คนก็เดี๋ยวเดี๋ยวคุณนิดจะเอาคนตัดไหมอีก
คนนึงแต่งตัวนักเรียนก็จะได้ยินในเรื่อง
ครับว่ามันเกิดอะไรขึ้นครับให้ค่ะก็อัน
นี้เขาคือเรื่องมันก็กายยังมีอยู่ว่า
เรื่องมีอยู่ว่าเธอก็คนตัดหมายคนนี้ครับ
เขาก็เข้าไปกินค่ะโอเคเข้าไปในป่าแถวเข้า
ไปในป่าบอกเขาเข้าไปในป่าเขาก็ไปทำเหมือน
ที่เขาทำทุกวันก็คือเข้าไปในป่าแล้วก็ไป
ตัดไม้ใช้อะไรหนักไม้คะจ่ายครับเขาใช้อัน
นี้ครับเขาใช้ขวานกับเราจะเรียกว่าขวาน
กับครูเอ๋ลอง
ขับๆให้ดูก็ได้ครับ
สักครู่นะคะ
กว่า
คุยจะวัด
โอเคเหมือนไหมคะเหมือนครับเหมือนอ่ะฮะ
โอเคค่ะกว่านิดหน่อยครับอ่ะช้าสาบสับให้
ออมเหมือนต้นไม้ให้มันขาดเหมือนในรูปเลย
ครับเขาก็อันนี้เราคนนี้จะขยายให้ดูเห็น
ไหมครับเนี่ยเป็นต้นไม้ที่พ่อใช้ขวานตัด
แล้วเนี่ยมันก็จะเป็นแบบนี้มันใกล้จะขาด
จะใช่
เป็นคนฟังนิทานไม่ดีเอ้า
เวลาเด็กๆเอกกะอ้าวมีเทพหาต้นไม้มี
เทพารักษ์แล้วคนตัดไม้ไปตัดต้นไม้
เทพารักษ์ไม่โกรธเหรอขอ
กินคนเดียวก็คิดนะว่าเอง
เทพารัตน์จะโกรธไหมเพราะว่าเทพารักษ์อะ
เขาอยู่ในต้นไม้ถ้าน้องไปตัดต้นไม้ก็
เหมือนเป็นเหมือนจะไปทำบ้านเขาให้มันทาง
แล้วก็พี่มีที่อยู่ชายอ๋อแต่ว่าเคยถามเขา
ก็แต่ละที่กับที่มันไทยนะคะในนิทานอีสป
อาจจะไม่ได้บอกที่มันใครเขาก็จะบอกว่าอ๋อ
คนตัดไม้ดีๆน่ะเขาก็จะไหว้ก่อนก่อโทษนะ
เทพารักษ์อ่ะขอต้นไม้อันนี้นะถ้าอยู่ที่
นี่ขอให้ยายแล้วก็ต้องจ่ายก็ออกเขาบอก
เทพารัตน์ก่อนที่จะต่างไม่งั้นเดี๋ยวเปิด
เทพารักษ์กำลังนอนอยู่ในต้นไม้แล้วป่ะ
โอ้ยใครว่าตัดต้นไม้
อันนี้เรื่องจริงนะที่ประเทศแถบต้นไม้
ใหญ่ๆค่ะต้นไม้ใหญ่ๆไม่ใช่ไปตัดเฉยๆนะคะ
เค้าจะต้องไหว้ขอนะคะ 200 ตับนะ
มันจะอันตราย
ลิขิตว่าในประเทศไทยเนี่ยเกี่ยวกับศาสนา
พุทธด้วยบังคับที่ถ้าเราทำอะไรในป่าเราจะ
ต้องขอก่อนเพราะว่าเราคิดว่าเราไม่ได้
อยู่ที่ปากก่อนค่ะมี
พื้นที่ป่าเขาก็จะมีมีเจ้าป่าอาจจะเป็น
เหมือนนั้นผีนักเรียนตอบแทนแต่ว่าดีๆแล้ว
ก็แข็งแรงแล้วก็มีเขตภาระ 1  2 อย่างนะ
ถ่ายเจ้าป่าเจ้าเขาจะได้ว่าจะเป็นป่าเจ้า
เขาจะใช้ตัดฟืนคุณนะเขานิสัยดีอ่าเขาหัว
ก่อนครับเขาก็ขอก่อนก็เขาขอก่อนแล้วเขาก็
ตัดตัดต้นไม้ขวานั่นแหละที่นี่เนี่ยเพราะ
เขาตัดตัดไปเรื่อยๆเนี่ยมันก็มีเรื่อง
อะไรเกิดอะไรขึ้นก็มันก็เป็นแบบนี้ครับ
ขวานของเขาเป็นยังไงคะมันขวาเนี่ยผมว่าก็
เพราะเขาสับสับต้นไม้ไปแล้วขวางมันก็หลุด
มือหมอแล้วไม่รู้อยากนี้เลยจบไป
มีเสียงแดงจ๋อมเลยนะน่าจะตูมไหมคะตรงๆไม่
พบขวานมันหนักเน้อดูแล้วต้นไม้ใหญ่กว่า
น่าจะไม่เล็กๆนะพรุ่งนี้นะจอมนี่คือเล็กๆ
นะคะขวาเล็กๆคุณมีก็คิดว่าเสียงจ๋อมเนี่ย
ฟังแล้วมันน่ารักดี
นายฮะจ่อมก็จองแบบถ้ามันตอบคุณหนักแต่มัน
ก็จะแบบตก
จากอ๋อมันไทยจะบอกว่าตกน้ำดังจ่อม
จบนั้นนำดังตู้ม
รู๋กระโดดลงน้ำอ่ะกระโดดลงสระว่ายน้ำ
เนี่ยจะดังตู้เฮ้ยดังตอบนี้ก็ได้
กู ah กูเอ๋ตัวไม่ใหญ่ไม่โตร่วมหรอกอ่ะ
ถึงต่อไปก็คือนี้คุณไม่เห็นครึ่งเดียว
เห็นครึ่งเดียวค่ะคือแม่เกศจะไม่ยืนหรือ
ว่าให้เห็น
สีหน้าขวานตกน้ำดังอ๋อมน่ารักจังเลยนะฮะ
เราทีเด็ดฟันก็ดังจ๋องเล่าให้ผู้ใหญ่ฟัง
ก็ได้ตู้
ก็อันนี้ครับเพราะว่าเขาอาจจะตอนที่ปาก
เนี่ยจะใช้แรงเยอะมันก็เลยป่ะตอนจังหวัด
ต่างๆแล้วมันอย่างนี้ออกไปเนี่ยมันก็เลย
พกเหนื่อยด้วยอ่ะคิดว่าเหนื่อยด้วย
เหนื่อยแป๊บมันก็หลุดมือนะคะเป็นเนี่ยพอ
หลุดมือมันก็ตกลงไปในน้ำ 5 คนตัดไม้ก็แบบ
ตกใจแล้วเอ้าขวานตกลงไปในบ่อในบึงน้ำ
เนี่ยหนองน้ำเนี่ยต้นไม้ต้นไม้ขาดไปยัง
ต้นไม้หรือยังขาดไม่หมดเลยยังรังเหลือง
ไม่ล้มใช่ไหมคะยังไม่มีหรอกยังไม่ล้มครับ
เขาก็แบบเอ้าทำยังไงเพราะว่าอยู่ในป่าถ้า
เรามีขวานอันเดียวค่ะเราถ้าเขาเดียวด้าน
เดียวคนนี้มีควันดำเดียวเด็กเด็กอันนี้ก็
อันก็ได้ค่ะไม่เป็นไร
บ้างก็ได้ป่านนี้ทำเดียวดาวเล่มแน่
ละกันคุณเล็กไม่ได้หาย
คืออะไรที่คมเขาก็จะเรียกว่าเล่มนะฮะ
อย่างที่จับแบบเนี้ยก็ดาว
แล้วก็เรียกมีด 1 เล่มใช่
แต่ก็ไม่เป็นไร
ไม่
ผิดนักเรียนครับขีดเมืองไทยก็คนไทยก็พูด
แบบเรานี่แหละค่ะเพราะคนไทยท่านนึกอะไร
ไม่ออกก็จะบอกว่าอันทุกข์นั้นนะคะ
ข่าวจ่าย
ลักษณนามเดี๋ยวนะคุณนิคเล่าต่อฮะโอเคครับ
ก็ก็เพราะขวาเนี่ยตกลงไปในน้ำใช่ไหมครับ
แล้วน้ำๆรึคนตัดไม้เนี่ยเขาก็แบบเองแล้ว
จะเอาขวานยังไงล่ะมันลงไปไม่ได้ผลน้ำมัน
ลึก
ครับนี้อ่ะเขาก็เหมือนครับตกใจละม้ายก็
ตัดยังไม่ได้ดีเลยเหมือนยังไม่มีอะไรเอา
กลับบ้านไปใช้หรือเอาไปขายต่อทางอะไรครับ
ถามที่นี้ครับก็
เทพารักษ์เนี่ยเขาก็เห็นว่าขวัญมันตกไปใน
น้ำแล้วฝันเล่มเนี้ยนะมันตกน้ำชายคนตัด
ไม้ก็แบบเขาเป็นคนดีไงครับขอโทดด้วย
เดี๋ยวๆดีไม่ดีเท็กเทพารักษ์รู้ว่าเขา
เป็นคนดีก็คิดว่าน่าจะเป็นคนดีเพราะเขาขอ
เทพารักษ์ก่อนตื่น
ก็จะตัดต้นไม้เขาขอก่อนก็เลยเคสว่าเป็นคน
ดี
รัฐเนี่ยเขาก็เลยมาช่วยครับอันนี้เหมือน
เค้าจะร้องไห้นะขอให้เธอพรัตน์ช่วยด้วย
ใช่ไหมใช่ไหมคิดว่านะครับคิดฮอดเขาเข้าจะ
ร้องให้ช่วยด้วยไม่มีขวานไม่มีขวานตัดต้น
ไม้วันนี้ก็ไม่มีเงินไม่มีเงินก็ไม่มี
เงินไปซื้อข้าวให้
แม่ลูกภรรยากิน
ต่อไปจะทำงานอะไรดีดีเพราะไม่มีขวานตัด
ต้นไม้แล้วน้องเอ้ย
โอเค
ต้นไม้ให้
ที่ดีครับก็เทพารักษ์เนี่ยก็เลยมาช่วยอัน
นี้ก็จะเป็นเทพรัตน์ที่เป็นเอ่อตะ
อีกนิดหน่อยเพราะหัวสีทอง
อาจารย์เทพารักษ์ไทยนะคะเราเปลี่ยนเป็น
เที่ยวต่างชาติแล้วนะคะก็จะพารักเขาก็มา
แล้วก็มาจากน้ำเลยนะคะคืออันนี้ครับก็
เป็นเทพารักษ์ในตอนแรกเขาก็ปิ๊งขึ้นมา
ก่อนเหมือนกับแล้วก็บอกว่าคุณเป็นใคร
ชายตอนแรกเนี่ยเทพารักษ์ที่ฉันมาในก็ยัง
ไม่มีขวางแบบนี้นะ
ครับก็มาจากฟื้นตกใจเลยฮะเขาก็ตกใจไหมจะ
เป็นคูนี้ก็ตกใจนะถึงเราจะขอหรือบอกกับ
เทพารัตน์แต่เราไม่เคยเห็นเทพารัตน์จริงๆ
ค่ะเทพารักษ์ขึ้นมาวิ่งเฮ้ยใครเนี่ยใคร
แต่ก็อีก
ใจตกใจนิดหน่อยแต่ก็อ๋อเขาคงมาดี
เป็นพนักงานแนะนำตัวก่อนนะคะใช่ฮะโอเค
เป็นๆเป็นคนตัดฟืนใช้เนี่ยอ๋อผมเป็นถ้า
เป็นเทพารักษ์เทพารักษ์ท่านเทพารักษ์ช่วย
ด้วยเนี่ยขวานของเราเนี่ยตกน้ำเงินน้ำที่
เนี่ยมันลึกมากเราว่ายน้ำไม่เป็น
เทพารักษ์เก่งไหม
เทพารัตน์ค่าเก่งนะเก่งนะเก่งเข้าช่วย
ด้วยเอาขวานขึ้นมาให้ได้ไหมจะได้ตัดฟืน
ได้ๆได้ๆๆเดี๋ยวข้าจะไปเอาขวานในน้ำมาให้
ขอบคุณเทพารักษ์ช่วยด้วยโอเคครับเทพรัตน์
เนี่ยก็ลงไปในน้ำแล้วก็ไปเอาขวานขึ้นมา
ที่ช่วงเนี้ยขวานที่เทพารักษ์เอาขึ้นมา
เนี่ยมันมี
มองสีทองเราก็สีเงิน
ตอนแรกเนี่ยเขาเอาขึ้นมาอันเดียวก่อนว่า
เป็นสีทองให้ไหมอันนี้เนี่ย
เทพลักษณ์คณะเทพารักษ์ขวานของฉันล่ะฮือ
นี่ไงสีทองอันนี้ใช่ไหม
เทพารักษ์ขวานของฉันไม่ใช่สีทองไม่เอา
โอเคเดี๋ยวข้าจะไปหาให้ใหม่เทพารักษ์ก็ไป
ในน้ำหาให้แล้วก็ได้เป็นสีเงินขึ้นมาค่ะ
ครับแล้วก็บอกไหนขวานของฉันล่ะอันนี้ไงสี
เงินใช่ไหมกูไม่ใช่เจ็บพารักอันนี้มันสวย
ไปขวานของฉันเป็นเหล็กเก่าๆจะไปตัดต้นไม้
นานแล้วโอเคเดี๋ยวข้าจะไปหาให้อีก 1
ครั้งขอบคุณเทพารักษ์เทพารักษ์ก็ลงไปใน
น้ำไปหาแล้วก็บอกว่าอันนี้ใช่ไหม
ใช่ขอบคุณมากๆขอขวานคืนจะได้ตัดต้นไม้ได้
โอเคเย้ได้แล้วก็ทอนเทพารักษ์เข็มแบบนี้
ครับเทพารักษ์ก็บอกว่าเจ้าเป็นคนซื่อ
สัตย์
จ่ายคนซื่อสัตย์ก็คือเป็นคนที่เหมือนกับ
ไม่ไกลไม่ใช่ของตัวเรา
จอดถึงจะเป็นขวานเก่าๆก็ยังจะเอาครับ Top
ตอนแรกแปบเทพารักษ์เอาขวางสีทองแล้วก็
ขวานสิเงินมาให้แต่ถ้าในใช่แต่ขอว่าไม่
ใช่ของตัวเองก็ไม่อ่านครับตายที่นี่เนี่ย
เทพารักษ์เนี่ยก็เห็นว่าผู้ชายคนนี้เนี่ย
คนตัดไม้เนี่ยเป็นคนซื่อสัตย์ค่ะกับเขาก็
เลยโอเคพระเจ้าเป็นคนซื่อสัตย์ข้าจะให้
ขวานสีเงินและสีทองด้วยงูสุนิถ้าเป็นคุณ
เนี้ยขวางสีทองเอาไว้ก็แหล
จริงๆตัวเล็กหน้าคุณนี้จะไม่เอานะ
ถ้าเป็นคนซื่อสัตย์
แต่ว่าในเรื่องนี้เนี่ยคนตัดฟืนก็อยากได้
ขวานของตัวเองไม่ไม่รู้เห็นทองก็ไม่เอา
ก็ไม่เอานะคะเห็นอะไรที่มีค่ามากกว่าไม่
เอาเพราะว่าไม่ใช่เนื้อเพลงเขาเป็นคนไม่
รู้ไม่เคยต้องตัวเองก็เลยไม่เอานะคะอะไร
ชายก็เกิดอะไรขึ้นคะต่อจากนั้นก็เขาก็ได้
ขวานใช่ไหมครับแล้วทิ้งเขาก็เลยกลับบ้าน
ครับกลับไปที่บ้านเนี่ยที่นี่ก็ไปคุยให้
เพื่อนเขาฟังถ้าพี่ทำกับหนูเหมือนกันที่
ตัดตัวเหมือนกันชายอันนี้ก็เป็นคนตัดฟืน
คนที่ 2 ค่ะชายเขาก็โทรกลับไปที่บ้านครับ
เข้าไปเป็นเล่าให้เพื่อนฟังว่าเนี่ยเมื่อ
กี้ไปตัดต้นไม้แล้วทำขวานตกน้ำค่ะแล้วก็
มีเทพารักษ์กับมาช่วยเอาขวานให้ขับค่ะ
แล้วเขาก็เล่าให้ฟังว่าเนี่ยเพราะว่าเขา
อ่ะทำขวานตกน้ำแล้วพอเทพารักษ์เนี่ยช่วย
เอาขวานขึ้นมาให้เนี่ยมันก็มีขวามีสีทอง
ขวานสีเงินทำเขตค่ะรักแม่ก็ให้ขวานั้นเขา
มาด้วยเขาก็เล่าทั้งหมดให้ฟังใช่มั้ยใช่
เราทั้งหมดที่เกิดขึ้นให้ฟังครับเนาะๆๆ
แล้วเพื่อนเขา
รู้สึกยังไงอ่ะเขาเขาได้ยินเพื่อนเขาก็
แบบอาหารสีทองไปขายในรวยๆเขาก็มีความคิด
แล้วแบบเขาบังคับอยากได้อยากได้แบบเพื่อน
บ้างเขาก็จริงๆเราจะพูดว่าอิจฉาได้มั้ย
เพราะว่าเห็นเพื่อนได้ก็อยากได้บ้าง
ได้เหมือนกันนะอิอิต้องหาได้
อยากได้เหมือนคนอื่น
ใช่ก็ถ้าอิจฉามันก็จะไม่ชอบเคลื่อนเลยหือ
โลกดีกว่าอยากได้
นกใช่ลูกชายเขาโลภอยากได้ขวานก็ต้องขวาน
เงินบ้างค่า k ที่บอกว่าเคารพเพราะว่าผู้
ชายคนนี้เขาตั้งใจเลยใช่ไหมคะๆเขาตั้งใจ
เลยว่าวันใจเป็นตั้งใจเข้าป่าไปหาเทพ
ปะหล่ะๆหาเทพารักษ์แบบอยากรวยทางลัด
มีเทพารักษ์ใจดีต้องไปขอ
ขอครับที่นี่เนี่ยเพราะเขาได้ยินใช่ไหม
ครับเขาก็เลยไปในป่าครับไปเดียวกันกับที่
เพื่อนเขาไปมาค่ะก็แต่เขาไปเนี่ยเขาไม่
ได้ตัดนะเข้าไปถึงเนี่ยเอาขวานที่เขามี
แล้วก็โยนลงน้ำเลยเอ้า
ๆนิดหน่อยใช่มะแล้วก็อุ้ย
จริงๆไม่ได้ตกจริงซึ่งอาจจะเหอะเออเอา
ขวานไปแปะต้นไม้แบบลึกๆแล้วก็น้ำ
ติดตั้งใจให้ขวางมีน้ำตาขวัญเขายังใหม่
หรือนั้นอ่ะหาใช่ใช่ครับก็ความตกน้ำครับ
แล้วก็ทำเหมือนกับเพื่อนก็เลยว่าเออฟังตก
น้ำ
มีไหมเนี่ยช่วยด้วยขวานตกหน้าร้องไห้ใช่
ก็ร้องไห้ก็เทพระก็เห็นแล้วก็วิ่งขึ้นมา
กดตัวที่มากดตัวขึ้นมาแล้วก็ถามเหมือน
เดิมว่าถ้าเหมือนกับเพื่อนครับว่ามีอะไร
High เขาก็บอกว่าขวางตกน้ำๆเดี๋ยวแป๊บ
นึงนะครับคุณดีเกิดจากคือเออ
ถามเสร็จแล้วก็เทพารักษ์ช่วยด้วยขวานตก
น้ำร้อนว่ายน้ำไม่เป็นจะกลับบ้านยังไงไม่
มีไม้ขายไม่มีเงินอื่นให้ร้องไห้เหมือน
ที่เพื่อนทำนะคะกไก่ครับก็เทพารักษ์ก็ได้
ยินแล้วก็โอเคเพราะเขารู้ว่าอ๋อมีเรื่อง
แบบนี้ได้เขาก็ไปช่วยเขาก็ลงไปในน้ำครับ
เทพารักษ์เหมือนกับทำกับเพื่อนเขาเจ็บ
เวลาขยันว่ายน้ำๆก็ขึ้นมาเป็นอย่าง
มากขวานสีทองใช่ไหม
ใช่แค่พอรักขวัญอันนี้แหละของฉันขวานสี
ทองครับพ่อเทพารักษ์เนี่ยได้ยินว่า
พระรักหวานอันนี้ของผมครับ
เทวารัตน์เขาบอกว่าโผรู้
ถ้ารู้โอ้ว่าอันนี้ไม่ใช่ของเจ้าเฮ้ย
เทพารักษ์ไม่ได้โกหกใช่จริงๆเอา
ข้ารู้เพราะว่าข้าเห็นว่าขวานที่ตกลงไป
เนี่ยเป็วันนี้
ที่ภารกิจเห็นด้วยหรอใช่ใช่ข้าเห็นก่อน
ที่จะปรากฏตัว
ให้เจ้าแล้วก็มาถามมาช่วยเจ้า
ขวานทองให้ด้วยก็ได้เทพารัฮ่าๆๆเราเป็นคน
โลภค่าไม่ให้ขวานทองค่าไม่ให้ขวานที่ทำตก
ด้วยแล้วให้ภาระก็ก็หายตัวไปเลยโอ้วแล้ว
ก็ชายคนนี้นะคะก็เป็นแบบนี้เลย
ไม่มีขวานตัดไม้ใช่ก็ไม่ได้ขวางทองด้วยๆ
เขาก็เข้าเทพารักษ์เนี่ยรู้ว่าเขาเนี่ย
เป็นคนโลก
ใช่ไม่เป็นคนโลกเป็นคนไม่ซื่อสัตย์ว่า
ขวานจริงๆเป็นอันไหนข้าก็เลยอ่ะแต่ถ้าเขา
บอกว่าไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ก็อาจจะได้ทั้งหมดอาจ
จะได้เหมือนเพื่อนครับช้าแต่พอเห็นทอง
ปั๊บโหโกหกกันทีช้าฉัน
ใช่ครบก็อันนี้ครับก็เป็นเรื่องนี้อ่าน
วันนี้ที่คุณนิคมาเล่าให้ฟังครับมันก็จะ
เป็นนิทานคนไทยเข้ามองคิดนั่งสอนใจใช่ไหม
ครับให้เอาเป็นคนซื่อสัตย์ไม่โกหกนะคะใน
โลก 3 ฉันไม่รู้อะไรที่ไม่ใช่ของเราอ่าน
ก็อย่าไปบอกว่าเป็นของเราชายทางก็ถ้าเป็น
คนโลกเหมือนคนตัดไม้คนที่สองเนี่ยจนมีผล
ตามมาว่าโลภมาก
ลาภอ่าน
ของของที่มีอยู่ก็จะหายไปด้วยของมีค่าก็
จะหายไปด้วยที่บ่เคยมีเพราะเราเป็นคนโลก
อยากได้มากๆ
อยากจะอยากได้ของคนอื่นเขาเดี๋ยวไปโกหกนะ
คะแล้วก็อย่าไปอิจฉาเพื่อนนะคะชายครับก็
ต้องทำดีเหมือนเพื่อนๆนะคะไม่ใช่อิจฉารถ
มีค่าโอเคขอบคุณมากคุณนี้เดี๋ยวกูเออหลับ
สบายนะคะ
หลับสบายพอได้ยินว่าการละครั้งหนึ่งหรือ
เปล่าอะไรครั้งหนึ่งนาน
ก่อนจบนักเรียนคะนิทานเรื่องนี้ชื่อ
เรื่องอะไรคะ
คนนี้คิดว่าไม่ยากนะเพราะว่าได้ยินตัว
ละครได้ยินอะไรหลายๆอย่างแล้วน่าจะน่าจะ
คิดได้น่าจะรู้ว่าเรื่องอะไรค่ะนักเรียน
ก็ลองใส่ในคอมเม้นดูค่ะว่ามีเรื่องอะไร
ให้นักเลงคอมเม้นท์เป็นภาษาชื่อเรื่อง
ภาษาอังกฤษใช่ไหมหรือภาษาไทยภาษาอังกฤษ
จริงๆทาบนักเรียนที่เค้ารู้ภาษาไทยอยู่
แล้วก็ได้เหมือนกันนะครับก็ได้นะๆครับใช่
โอเคก็วันนี้ก็ดูเรื่องของคุณนิดจบแล้ว
ค่ะงั้นคุณนี้กับพี่เอ๋ต้องไปก่อนนะคะเลย
ครับต้องไปก่อนแล้วเจอกันใหม่ครั้งต่อไป
ค่ะสวัสดีคะนักเรียนขอบคุณค่ะคุณนิคไม่
วายทานครับอ่ะ